i have a gut feeling this kind of
stuff's gonna be hitting this year at a
steady pace
[Music]
so
it's been a little while since we've
talked about
pr disasters for moves for major
hollywood stars i mean we kind of did
with joss whedon but that that was a
little bit more of a very specific deep
dive i'm talking about when i've had to
talk around characters such as unicrono
or james gunn or johnny depp or amber
heard so
we've got a little bit of that sort of
situation again
this time
evangeline lilly known for many things
be it lost be it
being stuck with a romantic love
triangle subplot in the hobbit movies
even after she was explicitly told they
wouldn't do that to her to more recently
playing the wasp in the marvel cinematic
universe
she has been cropping up in the news for
around about a month now off and on
related to
anti-vaccine
sentiments statements and support
so
i kind of want to talk about this
because
it's i i always do find it interesting
to look at how these things are playing
out and also to compare it to what has
happened before in some of the other
times that i have talked about this and
one other time when i haven't but is
relevant we'll get to that don't worry
about it
so with evangeline lilly let's first of
all cover the basic facts of what has
gone on
this kind of kicked off when she was
spotted at an anti-vaccination rally and
then later posted
images from said rally and voiced her
support for um being against vaccine
mandates on instagram now that already
kind of kicked off a
not great
just general sentiment around her we'll
talk about fallout and what people
think should happen and what i think
will happen not necessarily making a
massive judgment statement or what
should or shouldn't in this particular
case
but we'll get to that but as you would
expect um because a lot of the concerns
around
the kinds of people who decry
vaccination and vaccination mandates
um there was a lot of concerns and more
than a few people
fans especially
have been asking for her to be removed
from
the uh the marvel cinematic universe and
when she started posting this stuff even
some of her co-stars without naming her
in specific
but the timing makes it pretty clear
it's in response to that
clearly were
not
okay
with what was being said or what she was
associating herself with and
association's actually kind of gonna be
an important thing when we get to the
next thing that happened more recently
she put out a video basically
encouraging
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
to sit down and talk with the people
running the
convoy protests in ottawa if you don't
know what's going on there really really
really quick a bunch of people who are
against
vaccine and mask mandates and
some other stuff along those lines but
that's the main thing have basically
used a convoy a you know a number of
large
trailer carrying trucks to block traffic
in ottawa which is the canadian capital
uh as a form of protest it has actually
jammed up a lot of commerce it has hurt
both the canadian and the american
economies it's uh it's it's it's been a
whole thing and she put out a video
basically saying hey prime minister why
aren't you talking to these people
and that honestly
that's where we get into that
association thing that i mentioned
before
because unfortunately
whether she is aware or not
whether she cares or not i don't know
but the fact is that
some of the people not all but some of
the people involved in this convoy have
been waving around things like
confederacy flags and swastika imagery
and this is kind of the point where
here's the thing i don't personally
really know too many anti-vaccination
people anti-mandate or anti-vaxx but
what i will say if i'm going to extend
any kind of olive branch is if you're
only against mandates like government
mandates if that's all that you're
against which is all she's really said
firmly that she has an issue with
um she hasn't been as much like that
vaccines are bad but it's been a bit
more of a you can't say what we can do
with our bodies approach that's so
that's kind of been her angle the olive
branch that i will extend is that if
that is the angle that you come at this
from
it puts you in a very precarious
position
because there's a lot of incredibly
unsavory and downright dangerous
elements
that are not just fringe but are pretty
prominent within
anti-vaxx sentiments because
anti-mandate puts you in touch with
anti-vaxx anti-vax put you in touch with
a lot of conspiratorial stuff and
conspiratorial stuff puts you in touch
with
q anon and all this other stuff that
gets real toxic real fast and so i will
express a certain amount of sympathy
insofar as if that is truly all that she
has an issue with is the mandates
that does put her in a tough position
where
she is
just by the nature of what she's
standing for standing next to some
really unsavory people that said
actually calling for justin trudeau to
speak with the convoy specifically when
not only is this known about some of the
elements in the convoy but trudeau
himself has called that out
so basically he's already said i see
some of the incredibly dangerous hateful
sentiments and imagery being shown in
this convoy and that is why i think it's
dangerous for you to then go i think you
should talk to them that's hmm
it's not a great look
but that's the basic core of what has
gone on at time of recording if i'm
really unlucky between when i shoot this
and when it's supposed to go up more
stuff will happen and i'll have to
reshoot this entire thing
but if you just heard me say that
nothing else major happened and i get to
just put it up as is we'll see
so
it's interesting to talk about how the
fallout has come around this as i said
there have been calls amongst fans to
replace her uh within the mcu
the thing is
this is a little bit different than if
we were to compare i feel like in many
ways one of the most relevant
comparisons is to gina carano who
got in trouble and uh ultimately
was uh not uh allowed to return for star
wars related things uh specifically on
the mandalorian and she might have even
been considered for her own spin-off
show before that because she expressed a
number of things
including anti-mask anti-vaccination
sentiments but it also then snowballed
into uh conspiracies around the election
and uh ultimately the straw that broke
the camel's back was uh making uh
comparisons of
things that she was talking about to the
holocaust which
that that was the point that pretty much
everyone and we're done
and so far at least evangeline lilly
does not appear to be on the same path
for a couple of reasons she has as i
said really narrowed down her public
statements and her social media posts to
specifically the idea of mask mandates
and so far it has not ballooned out into
all this other stuff
that happened with gina carano now it is
interesting because we know with gina
carano it was told to her by both her uh
actual uh management in terms of you
know her talent agents and the people
who she worked for at disney and
lucasfilm
you need to stop causing all these stirs
and then she didn't that's when her
contract wasn't renewed
with eventually lilly it's possible that
those conversations could be happening
i'm slightly less inclined to think that
they would be in this case though
because as i said it's much more
narrowly focused
um
than
the issues uh that went on with gina
chronower that said it's not impossible
there may be conversations going on with
her
but i i
kind of doubt it so the question
then becomes
would they actually remove her
or would they keep her
and this is where i kind of want to make
another comparison to someone who i
haven't talked about before
and that's leticia wright who plays
shuri in the black panther movies now i
didn't talk about letitia wright
previously because a lot of what's gone
on around her in the conversation around
her has been
highly speculative to a degree that i
wasn't really comfortable debunking a
lot of it because the amount of concrete
things around her and what's going on is
way less than people seem to think
because i saw some bonkers stuff thrown
around as fact in my own comment
sections then looked into it went
maybe that's possible that i seriously
doubt so
quick breakdown there
late last year leticia wright shared a
video on social media and that original
video
had a number of things going on it had
anti-vaxx was the main thing about it
but there was also some transphobic
stuff and it was a very unpleasant video
it's a video that's not even up on
youtube anymore it was found as
violating terms of service so the
thing's gone
now she has a certain amount of
deniability in that she did not create
that video she simply shared it and one
called out for that her response was
i'm gonna go with soft because she
didn't double down which is also
something evangeline lilly so far has
not really done she eventually lily is
stuck to her guns at the same level but
she hasn't doubled down the way gina
carano did
letitia wright basically said look i'm
not saying that these are my thoughts
i'm saying we should be asking questions
about these things which
you know still inclines me to think
those probably were her thoughts but at
the very least it demonstrates uh an
understanding that it would be very bad
for her to say that out loud
so
since then
most of the things that have been
reported about letitia wright have been
misconstrued or highly speculative so
during the filming of the sequel to
black panther wakanda forever she uh
went back to
britain because she sustained an injury
on set that was initially believed to be
a minor injury when she actually got
back home and was being treated it was
found out she had a it was either a
fractured collarbone or a fractured
shoulder
uh it was one of the two and a
concussion so it was a much more serious
injury than expected so that lengthened
the amount of time that the production
was put on hiatus because they shot
everything they could shoot without her
but then they had to hold and wait for
her and that went on longer than thought
uh initially because she needed more
time to recover now it got reported it
got said in the hollywood reporter who
and this they didn't say this was the
case but they speculated it might be and
then i saw it repeated elsewhere as if
it was fact which was there was
speculation
that since she is
likely unvaccinated it might be
difficult for her to get back into the
country because some of the restrictions
that were going on with travel at the
time and she might not be able to resume
filming now we don't know for a fact
whether or not leticia wright is or
isn't vaccinated given the stuff that
she shared before i would say it's
likely and it's not an unfair assumption
to say that she is not vaccinated but we
don't know that for a certainty and
there was definitely never any official
statements that that was part of the
delay in her returning that was simply
speculated upon another thing the
hollywood reporter said was that she was
espousing anti-vaxx
views on set
that's never been backed up by any other
reporting and it was an anonymous source
on that which doesn't make it untrue but
it does make it not have a lot of
foundational fact behind it now the
reason i bring all that up in a video
about evangeline lilly is
i think there's a decent chance
marvel will cut evangeline lilly loose
but i don't think they're going to cut
leticia right loose
because there's a little bit of
difference going on here
you could make on the one hand in both
cases they in the films that we've seen
so far at least they are important
supporting characters
but not the core leads
so why is it
different well first of all
the reporting on wakanda forever is that
shuri is going to be put front and
center as a much bigger focus if not the
actual lead character of the film since
chadwick boseman very regrettably passed
away
so there's that first of all but second
of all evangeline lilly who has already
shot ant-man 3 for the record so she's
appearing in that no matter what because
it's already filmed
but that if that is done the way
most of these sorts of uh individual
series have been done with marvel
that's probably going to if not be
designed as a complete closeout of a
trilogy going to be designed as a
well that works as a stopping point for
this story they did it with iron man 3.
the intention is to do that with
guardians of the galaxy i know we are
getting a fourth one but they did pretty
much do that with
uh thor ragnarok these things are
largely being set up
as little trilogies of films now of
course she could still appear in any
number of things after that but if
narratively the wasps
use and the things that like audiences
would have expected of the character are
fulfilled by the end of the third
ant-man well then
they don't really need to bring her back
and again it's not like she's actively
shooting something that they need to
fire her from it can be a bit like the
gina carano thing now while it was
reported gina carano was fired the truth
is her contract was not extended uh so
there is a slight difference in that and
that i could see also happening with
evangeline lily they simply choose to
not pick up her option because even if
they are or were originally planning to
include her in say whatever the next
big team up movie is be it avengers or
something else that
whatever that ends up being is in very
early planning stages right now
like
the marvel cinematic universe at the
moment
in the wake of end game has backed off
the big massive team ups they're doing a
bit more crossover continuity stuff but
the cross um
franchise team-ups have eased off a bit
at least in terms of big multiple
characters
we're seeing a bit more casual um into
uh interactions and crossovers with
things like doctor strange showing up in
spiderman no way home but the big stuff
seems to all be on hold because end game
was so big they kind of have to like
wait before trying to do that again they
have to wait for the memory to have end
game to fade at least a little so
whatever is going on with those right
now that's in early planning stages
early enough that if they had been
planning to use her they could remove
her
with leticia wright
if she is becoming as front and center
as it is believed that she would be
then that's going to be harder to cut
her loose especially if this was
conceived as a middle chapter in
ultimately
what may end up being a three film story
as some of these have ended up being so
with leticia wright i think
cutting her loose
is going to be
a lot more noticeable i have a feeling
and granted we haven't seen the movies
yet so i could be wrong about this but i
have a feeling that by the end of the
third ant-man movie most people will
probably be
okay if the wasp doesn't come back i
mean that's not to say there aren't fans
of the wasp but i'm saying they won't
feel like oh but we didn't like get that
full character story and i think that's
probably more likely to be the case with
shuri in the follow-up black panther now
the other thing is that leticia wright
after that stuff went down basically
deleted all of her social media stuff
which means she has not gotten into more
trouble at least publicly as i said
there were the reports of her possible
onset behavior and if that is true
that might be the one thing that could
cause issue
because
it
it creates
just a bad working environment and if
other actors don't want to work with her
because she's going off on conspiracy
narratives on set allegedly then that's
a much bigger problem because as long as
she stays off social media she's not
going to be a pr problem again
so
as long as that isn't the case which i
said i'm not
i'm not really sure i believe that a
hollywood reporter also said that she uh
replaced her management her talent
management
uh and that may have been over her views
on vaccination again it's a lot of
innuendo and i'm not saying it's
implausible or definitely not true but
there just isn't a lot behind that right
now so
unless she really starts going full
blown conspiracy not or gets back onto
social media and starts sharing that
stuff again i think she's probably going
to be okay evangeline lilly on the other
hand while i as i said she is not
doubling down and getting into worse and
worse and worse
sorts of things that connect to being
anti-mandate
that is something that she is not
keeping quiet about you know she had her
initial appearing at the protest and
then
later on the video uh directed at justin
trudeau that said it's still at least a
little bit better than gina carano
because gina chrono was basically just
throwing this stuff out into the ether
evangeline lilly does appear to be doing
it in a much more targeted political way
like addressing it specifically at the
prime minister and uh you know actually
showing up at a protest as opposed to
just
trying to take people off with online
posts
so
she does seem to have the strength of
her convictions a bit more whether or
not that's actually going to be of any
help to her in either her image or
maintaining this role i don't
know i'm inclined to say
probably not
but
certainly if you were to compare i don't
think it'll be
if if she never appears again as the
wasp i don't think it'll be the harsh
distancing we gotta get her away from
this stuff and we don't want her name
associated with what we do sort of thing
that happened with gina carano i don't
see that happening with evangeline lilly
unless
she falls down the rabbit hole of far
more conspiracy-laden
and harmful
stuff um and that's not to say there
aren't problems with being anti-mandate
but that's at least a philosophical
position i think most people can at
least understand even if they don't
agree with
it's just that it it can send you down a
rabbit hole into stuff that's
frankly pretty indefensible but she's
not there right now
so i don't see the harsh backing away
and not wanting any association from her
that happened with gina carano
that being said
i will not be surprised and i'm kind of
expecting
that her appearance as the wasp in
ant-man
quantum mania
will be the last time we'll see her in
the mcu
so
that's that's where things are at and
that's what i think is the most likely
trajectory
what are your thoughts on all this and i
know
i know that mandates vaccinations etc
are very heated very personal topics try
and be respectful to me to evangeline
lilly to letitia wright and two each
other
in the comments
as long as you can do that drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it patreon is how i am able to do
this as my living any support you can
give me does help ensure that this whole
thing keeps going but even if you're not
able to do that like shares and
subscribes also help me out there's a
whole bunch of links down there as well
to all sorts of stuff i have books for
sale i have merch i'm on twitch check
all that out
but don't worry too much about it either
because at the end of the day what i
really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
patreon shout outs thank you to turok
shane ross oliver b melinda walters
robin powell for nobulax the poodle
edelon tracy scrabbit dharma michael
doyle vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor robin moore
shayla gourley and bookworm
you can support me as well
hear me mispronounce your name
sure i got some of those wrong
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]